Patrick Pichat bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
associés chez Inovia fond
d'investissement mais vous êtes surtout
l'ancien c'est comme ça vous aviez fait
les manchettes l'ancien directeur
financier de chez Google un Québécois
qui arrivait là c'est quand même quelque
chose incroyable vous êtes resté là
plusieurs années
et vous avez été sur le conseil
d'administration de Twitter que vous
avez dirigé jusqu'à il y a un an mais
vous étiez encore sur le Conseil jusqu'à
tant que Monsieur mascarive comment ça
s'est passé il vous aura envoyé vous et
tous les autres du conseil
d'administration comment ça s'est passé
pour vous personnellement cette
transition là la transition c'est très
facile parce que comme
c'est facile de dire il y aura envoyé
tout le conseil mais le conseil a tous
démissionné en réalité notre job comme
conseil d'administration comme
administrateur du moment que la
transaction est fermée
tu déclares victoire fait après ça tu
lui dis bonne chance monsieur j'ai eu
des allers-retours on fera pas toute
l'histoire pour les gens mais ça a été
très complexe est-ce que maintenant vous
êtes dit il n'achète pas finalement
l'argent entre le repas non parce que on
a un petit comité
pour la transaction moi Brett et mars va
donc trois des administrateurs puis
ilon a signé un contrat où il a accepté
d'acheter la société
sans doute
accepter bien signer de sa main j'achète
la compagnie tel quel avec juste
l'information publique alors une fois
qui a fait ça
il y a plus de recours pour dire je vais
apprendre quelque chose qui est
différent qui m'empêche d'acheter des
sociétés
44 milliards qui le payaient est-ce
qu'il y a trop payé
les actionnaires que je représentais je
pense pas que c'est le cas ils sont en
fait très heureux on a suivi nos
actionnaires à travers tous les mois de
cette campagne puis nous actionnaires
étaient avec le conseil à chaque moment
alors on est très heureux du prix qu'il
a payé puis je veux rappeler à mes
habitants un milliard c'est 1000
millions c'est 44 mille millions qui est
payé pour la société incroyable c'est
énorme 237 millions d'abonnés Twitter là
deux choses l'une on assiste soit un
chaos extraordinaire qui va déboucher
sur un grand succès ou un chaos qui va
déboucher peut-être sur une faillite
est-ce que vous avez peur que Twitter
meurt
non je pense que c'est une société qui
est résiliente ça veut pas dire qu'elle
va pas faire faillite parce que il faut
séparer
la bilan de la société elle-même mais
c'est pas certain non plus qu'elle va
réussir avec ce nouveau leadership puis
la bonne nouvelle c'est que sur Internet
quand les gens n'aiment pas un produit
il y a un autre qui apparaît le
lendemain matin puis tout le monde
s'effacé de sauter sur les nouveaux
produits mais est-ce que vous vous savez
les choses qu'on ne sait pas y a-t-il
derrière le chaos je répète un plan là
il y a renvoyé dans des conditions
presque sauvages
3500 personnes
il y a moins de vérifications d'identité
de sorte que on ne sait plus si le
crochet bleu et gage de vérité ou pas
etc est-ce que vous vous avez peur de ce
qui est en train de faire
si j'ai peur pour l'appeler de mon côté
non parce que je pense que
tu as beaucoup de plaisir à regarder
l'expérience c'est pour ça que ta femme
deux trois semaines tu regardes
qu'est-ce qui se passe tu vois que ok il
faut attacher ça arrive pour les
prochains mois avec avec les lois dans
la tête de Twitter je pense que Twitter
c'est un animal c'est une société que
tout le monde aime critiquer c'est une
société que tout le monde aimer dire
vous savez pas comment opérer vos choses
chez Twitter puis monsieur masque a
décidé de venir nous dire comment opérer
nos choses cette photo puis là il y a
une belle opportunité de nous montrer
comment ça fonctionne mais ce que je
pense que vous nous dites c'est bonne
chance parce que c'est mal parti là
depuis trop de chance
des employés
puis on a vu en fait un signal qui est
très clair s'il y a fallu qu'il rappelle
des gens
alors qu'il y en avait besoin pour les
opérations critiques ça ça prouve que il
est pas un contrôle de qu'est-ce qui est
vraiment important à Twitter encore et
savez-vous si lui-même si il y a un plan
où on assiste en direct un accident de
charge
on assiste en direct à une belle
expérience
et vous ça vous amuse vous avez fait de
l'argent avec ça les actionnaires mais
j'ai servi j'ai servi mes actionnaires
puis comme je l'expliquais dans d'autres
médias ok au Canada on aurait eu un
débat très plus profond sur Twitter
parce que au Canada si j'avais été un
administrateur j'ai une obligation
envers la société envers la compagnie
elle-même et tous ces intervenants les
employés la communauté aux Etats-Unis
quand est un down wear Corporation d'une
société
pour ceux qui savent pas à l'époque
oubliez pas au moment où on a signé le
dire il y a des gens qui ont dit est-ce
qu'on la donne trop rapidement à passer
cher
une des questions fondamentales que les
gens se posent
c'est bon il est libertarien
grand bien lui en face puis le droit
d'être ce qu'il veut mais peut-on
laisser libre cours à tout sur un réseau
social comme Twitter ou on doit
contrôler les faits et si on contrôle
les faits qui contrôle les faits vous en
êtes dans votre réflexion là-dessus moi
j'ai beaucoup aimé du temps que j'étais
sur le Conseil puis les années que j'ai
servi de la satiété on avait les règles
de Twitter puis tu veux une plateforme
ouverte où tout le monde peut s'exprimer
puis la question c'est où est-ce que tu
mets les barrières dans le quartier
ils sont encore publiques vous pouvez
aller vérifier c'est des choses super
simples mais très profondes
à la promotion de la violence c'est
là-dessus qu'on a perdu Trump pas sur le
reste il pouvait dire ce qu'il voulait
mais tant que tant que janvier ça a été
l'eau qui a fait déborder exactement
puis la même chose sur la promotion de
en anglais du soft de se faire mal à
soi-même il y a 6 ou 8 règles à Twitter
puis de la minute que tu franchis cette
langue tu es plus dans le carré de sable
pour le reste c'est important on a le
bénéfice d'une société ouverte regardez
les sociétés qui sont des attachés comme
la Corée du Nord et
on a l'avantage nos sociétés ouvertes il
faut les protéger ses institutions là
puis de Twitter c'est une belle
institution qui sert très bien à ça mais
maintenant avec qui ça va être il
apprend lui-même
commence à le quitter parce que
justement il décide d'être chef
éditorialiste de sa plateforme alors que
là il commence à l'apprendre vite que il
faut avoir des règles plutôt serrées
puis bien réfléchi avant de laisser la
plateforme ouverte vous êtes vous êtes
financier vous connaissez bien ces flux
d'argent pour un homme aussi riche que
lui est-ce que si il se passe moins
l'expression mais s'il se casse la
gueule si ça ferme sous sa forme
actuelle est-ce que c'est un trou énorme
ou il va continuer puis bonsoir non
c'est la beauté d'idée c'est l'homme le
plus riche au monde je savais qu'il
était propriété
capable d'écrire le chèque
au monde fait 44 milliards
13 milliards de dettes il y a d'autres
gens qui ont investi aussi fait que il y
a pas mis tout le 44 milliards puis il
peut se permettre ça ok alors si vous
aviez à vous projeter à faire un pari
est-ce que il va revenir sur terre sans
jeu de mots puis il va réussir à
accepter qu'il y a des contrôles qui a
des règles de sorte que les publicités
restent que les gens restent que on
continue à partager de l'information le
plus librement possible
je voudrais la réponse que dès Queen
avait répondu quand il y avait une
maladie au début des années 80 il a
demandé qu'est-ce qu'il pensait de la
Révolution française il y avait répondu
c'était un peu trop tôt
[Rires]
à voir qu'est-ce qu'il fera avec ça vous
Patrick pichet vous continuez dans un
fond d'investissement
vous trouvez que on prend pas assez de
risques peut-être avec des capitaux au
Canada au Québec il faut encourager ça
plus ouais on a une société on a les
plus belles universités on a plein de
propriétés intellectuelles on des
chercheurs extraordinaires Montréal
Milla on a tout ça avec nous on a
l'universel
on devrait avoir un chat peut faire à
tous les ans au Canada puis pour moi ce
qui est important c'est non seulement on
a besoin de ces sociétés là les soutenir
en faire des champions mondiaux
puis s'assurer que le capital qui est
mis dans cette société revienne chez
nous au lieu d'aller donner de l'argent
au fond d'investissement de Stanford
univers série ou des grands autres pour
moi c'est ça qui est important c'est
pour ça que j'ai investi puis j'ai en
train de bâtir une via pourquoi vous
partez pas le prochain Twitter ici alors
du Québec puis on va irradier c'est pas
dit c'est pas dit que ça sera pas fait
parce que justement si on voit Twitter
ça on va vraiment dans une dans le mur
c'est la beauté c'est que plein
d'opportunités encore une fois et au
Canada
pour ce type d'entreprise Patrick pichet
merci beaucoup d'être venu nous parler
vous venez vous êtes entre autres au
Québec parce que vous allez protéger des
acteurs et des hectares de forêt dans le
nord de l'outawa c'est l'ancienne
seigneurieuse Papineau Monseigneur Laval
Louis Joseph
puis maintenant nous on le donne à la
communauté avec l'Université du Québec
en Outaouais avec conservation de la
nature Canada on donne ce territoire là
pour le protéger à perpétuité en faire
laboratoire de recherche pour la
communauté au plaisir monsieur pichet